vor vier milliarden jahren geschah etwas
wirklich unfassbar ist ein riesiger
gesteinsbrocken aus dem all rammte die
erde und was genau geschah dann das hat
es ja nicht so ganz klar jetzt hat der
geophysiker psylock vielleicht die idee
was damals dramatisches wahrscheinlich
passierte und die folgen jetzt den
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
wie entstand eigentlich der mond eines
ist klar bei einer unglaublichen
katastrophe bisher war man der ansicht
dass er quasi aus der erde damals
herausgesprengt wurde aber so ganz passt
diese vorstellung einfach nicht das
mondgestein und das der erde
die beiden die sind ziemlich homogen zu
einheitliche jetzt hat der geophysiker
psylock eine neue idee als der brocken
die erde traf wurde die erde seiner
ansicht nach komplett zerstört was übrig
blieb war eine wolke aus gas und
flüssigem gestein unglaublich heiß aber
kein planet mehr die erde war komplett
zerstört worden so meint er es dauerte
dann nur noch ein paar hundert jahre bis
sich die wolke wieder verdichtete doch
etwas war anders als vorher ein kleiner
teil der materie bildete einen eigenen
klumpen den mond mit dieser idee können
viele probleme gelöst werden und lockert
es nachgerechnet genau so funktioniert
es in seiner simulation danach hat sich
nach dem zusammenstoß eine sogenannte
sinne sehr gebildet an sich schnell
drehende donath aus flüssigem oder zu
staub zerstört und gestein damit wäre
erklärt warum die erde nur einen montag
warum er den gesamten drehimpuls des
erde mond systems trägt und vor allem
warum die isotopenzusammensetzung des
mond gesteins mit dem der erde nahezu
identisch ist und das ist nur möglich
wenn dieser riesige brocken sich
komplett mit der erde und dem mond
vermischt hat was nur geht wenn sich als
zwischenstadium einem semester gebildet
hat und noch eine besonderheit des
mondgestein es passt zu dieser hypothese
flüchtige elemente wie kalium und
natrium können im außenbereich einer
solch solchen es ja ins all entweichen
das mondgestein würde weniger von diesen
elementen enthalten und genau das ist
der fall noch ist die fachwelt sehr
skeptisch aber bisher ist das die
einzige die wirklich alles erklären kann
nur eine solche nächstes jahr wurde noch
nie beobachtet vielleicht wird ja das
james webb teleskop ein solches phänomen
dann bald finden allerdings wird sich
nach neuesten meldungen der stadt
verschieden was wirklich sehr schade ist
geldmangel ist wohl der grund wenn ihr
als erstes neues zu diesem thema und zu
allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
endet meine telefonnummer
bei whatsapp das geht hier mit diesem
linklink dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert er könnte die
über mich in der redaktion vom klick zum
mitmachen und mehr themen vorschlagen
oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen und
somit bestimmen was hierbei klicks um
passiert der direkte draht zu mir
einfach hier draufklicken ja und
natürlich nicht das abo und genau die
glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken 1000 raketen zu
mars ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran